-It is time for the
Name That Song Challenge!
Here we go!
-♪ Name That Song,
Name That Song ♪
♪ Challenge ♪
-My opponent tonight stars
in the new movie
"King Richard,"
out November 19th.
And his memoir, "Will,"
dropped today.
Give it up for the one,
the only, Will Smith!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
-How you doing, man?
-I love you, buddy. Come on!
Look at that.
-Hey!
-Yeah. Feel the love
right there. Come on.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-Look at that.
You gotta feel the love!
-Yes. I'm feeling the love.
That is beautiful.
-Will Smith! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love you, dude!
-That is fantastic.
-Ah.
-Philly!
-We love you, dude. All right.
-Oh, that's fantastic.
-Here's how it works.
The Roots are going to start
playing a song
one instrument at a time.
-Ooh.
-And Will and I can buzz in
and guess as soon
as we know the song.
If you guess wrong, the other
person gets a chance to steal.
-To steal?
-Yeah.
You can play along at home.
Roots, let's hear the first --
Am I going to get these, Quest?
-Okay.
-I don't know.
Are you going to get these?
-All right.
-We're going to see.
-Let's hear the first song.
All right, whenever --
Whenever you are ready.
-Two, three, and...
♪♪
-You know that?
-Yeah.
♪ Ba-ba-ba-ba ♪
♪ It's like a jungle sometimes ♪
♪ It makes me wonder
how I keep from going under ♪
Whatever that song is.
[ Laughter ]
-Um, it -- "The Message"?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughing ]
-You did that on purpose.
[ All talking at once ]
-[ Mumbling ]
-No, that's not how I rapped!
-♪ Sometimes
it makes me wonder ♪
[ Laughter ]
-[ Beeping ]
-Uh, Will for the steal.
-Oh, please!
I knew -- Gosh.
Darn. I'm breaking a sweat.
Okay. All right. Here we go.
Now let's go. Next song.
Here we go. I got it.
-Three, four...
♪♪
-"Safety Dance."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hold on a second. Is that --
Was that a white --
white-people check?
[ Laughter ]
-That's my jam, too.
-All right.
-Yeah. Yeah. No.
He's trying to mix it up.
He's trying to keep it
racially balanced. Yeah.
-Yeah. "Safety Dance."
-See? Because all Black --
We know that song as
"You Can Dance If You Want To."
We don't know the...
-Yeah, I would have done it.
[ Vocalizing melody ]
It would've been my turn
for that.
-Yeah.
It's like a jungle sometimes.
-So we're -- So we're --
It counts as a tie?
-We're tied right now.
-Here we go. Come on, Roots.
-Okay. Let's go.
-I'm psyched.
-Three, two, one...
♪♪
-Aah!
-Uh, the -- Uh, uh --
Hold on, hold on! Hold on!
♪ Saw me again,
looking for your friend ♪
Uh, Lauryn Hill.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
-Yes.
It's Lauryn Hill.
Um, what's the --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah!
No, no, no! We heard enough!
We heard enough!
No! We heard enough!
-Oh, I'm blanking
on the title of the song.
-Well, I'm not.
[ Laughter ]
[ Drum roll ]
Whoo!
-[ Mumbling lyrics ]
♪♪
-♪ That thing, that thing ♪
♪ That thing ♪
That's it?
-Ohh! I can't believe
I lost the title.
-Whew. Whew.
-"Wop"!
-[ Beeping ]
-We -- No, no. We didn't
even start playing yet.
-Oh, sorry.
-Yeah, yeah. Here we go.
-Sorry.
-All right. Here we go.
I'm leading by one, I believe.
-Okay.
-Two. One, two, three.
♪♪
-"Maneater"?
-[ Dinging ]
-No! Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got -- I was there.
I wasn't there
until the chorus came in.
-♪ Only come out at night ♪
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was good. That was good.
That was great. That was great.
I should have got that one.
-Okay. That was good.
-I should have got that one.
-Hey. This is the last one.
-This is the last one.
You're killing me
right now, too.
You're like -- You're really --
You're beating me badly.
-No, no.
Will, here's the thing.
-Yeah.
-This last one here
is worth 10,000 points,
so it's anyone's game.
-Oh! Okay. Let's go.
-All right.
This is the last one.
Wait. Let me just say something.
Because I've played this before
on the show.
I never cheat, but usually --
Roots, you play a song
that's somehow connected
to the person I'm playing with.
So I'm assuming
that this is one of your songs,
so I'm already gonna maybe
just buzz in and guess.
-Oh. That's strong.
-[ Beeping ]
-Whoo!
Wow!
-You ready?
-"Miami" is too obvious.
-Right.
[ Beeping ]
That's "Gettin' Jiggy Wit It."
-No, I'm not doing that.
-Okay.
-I just did that.
-I know what those drums are.
I know those drums.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay.
-He's playing with us.
Here we go.
♪♪
[ Beeping ]
Is that Willow Smith,
"Meet Me at Our Spot"?
-Oh, my gosh!
-Yeah. Yeah. Ohh!
Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Come on! Ohh!
That's my man right there!
Will Smith, everybody!
That's how you do it!